I'm speaking to you today as
a representative of Monarch.
Monarch is a global
collaboration
of governmental and
scientific agencies
dedicated to the study
of massive unidentified
terrestrial organisms, or
MUTOs, including the creature
we know as Godzilla.
Now our mission
is to protect you,
the citizens around the world.
We bring the best minds and the
most cutting-edge technology
to this purpose, including the
early warning system that was
triggered in Seattle yesterday.
Unfortunately, this time,
it was just a false alarm,
and we regret any distress
this may have caused.
But I take great
comfort in knowing
robust systems are in place
to give us ample warning
in a real emergency.
Listen, I know that
the events of G-Day,
they rocked the world--
a world where
everything that we love,
everything that we
hold dear, it just
could be gone in an instant.
And let me tell you as a
mother, I share your fear.
But this is now the
world we live in.
Monsters are an inescapable
reality, a constant threat
that we must learn to survive.
And I believe we can.
Together, I believe we will.
That is my commitment to you.